different looking lineup for alex cora
tonight give her the particulars on
michael king 26 year old right hander
who is occupying corey kluber spotting
the rotation currently
last started on sunday his first start
of the year at detroit and was a loser
in a six to two tigers win that night 26
year old went to boston college yankees
got him in a trade from the marlins and
he hasn't done much so far but he has a
big chance to make a name for himself
tonight this is only his sixth big
league start his one win came in relief
red sox snapped a three-game losing
streak by salvaging the series in
houston with a win yesterday santana
pops up
all by himself on the left side of the
infield is giovanni your shella for
route number one
just underway one gone base is empty the
3-2 home to verdugo is swung on and
lined into left-center field
gardner stumbles as he gets there and
verdugo is happy with the one out single
to gone now with the runner aboard for
xander bogarts just two hits in the four
game series against the astros one of
the big red sox bats who was countered
by houston pitching
0-1 pitch is pounced right through the
hole into right field nothing fancy
there just slap it the other way and the
red sox have runners at first and second
with two gone you're right just a slap
the other way but a good job by bogarts
the pitch is not that bad from michael
king's standpoint down and away
everest has had a very good year recent
results not withstanding 43 runs bad in
leads all american league third baseman
and homers rbis slugging an ops let's
see if the yankees stay firm here on
owen two
they do and devers was ready for it
oh
man
three run homer by rafi devers
that's up where the big boys live
and that's one too many fastballs but
that's the capabilities he has one of
the most productive and certainly with
extra base hits what a boost that is for
denver's coming off that feudal series
in houston three nothing boston two outs
into the game and that pitch above the
belt which is a more difficult pitch for
a left-hand hitter to get two take a
ride in the shopping cart rafi
it is native aldi on the mound for the
red sox 31 year old veteran right-hander
in his 10th major league season one of
those seasons was with the yankees five
and a third in his last
appearance no runs we mentioned only one
home run he's given up and he is a hard
thrower one of the best fastballs in
baseball a couple of first-inning
singles and a three-run homer has opened
the scoreboard early tonight as la
mayhew has a base head back up the
middle carlos stanton digs in for new
york now nine homers 24 rbis for one of
the big run producers in the yankee
lineup
on the ground past the shortstop bogarts
and here come the yankees in the bottom
of the first just be one of those nights
in what might in fact be the last year
that the d.h is only in the american
league jd leads a mall in hits runs
score batting average on base percentage
and ops among many categories
there's a ground ball and a fair ball
into the corner and left
let's see if martinez tries to stretch
it into a double he does and slides to
avoid the tag wow
put a little fernando tatis junior slide
out of very creative puts it into second
gear nice base running
leads things off in the boston fourth
still three nothing red sox
quick strikeout
of hunter improve one god oh and two to
the switch hitter marwin gonzalez
got him yeah see nice breaking ball
four strikeouts for both starters
tonight with two gun and the base is
empty it'll be christian vasquez
standing in
he struck out the side
and he did so on a total of nine pitches
an immaculate inning
well what does michael king do for an
encore after an immaculate inning in the
fourth he'll get a quick out on
christian arroyo to open the fifth
[Applause]
danny santana on a 1-0 pitch so three
pitches and two more outs for michael
king i think a best case scenario for
aaron boone was
five innings out of michael king but
he's been so super efficient here in the
fourth and fifth might be tempted to
think about a sixth inning with him
tonight i'm with you
i mean come on now
four pitches i mean come on those are
stress-free innings he pitched another
five nobody saw it going this way after
the three-run homer in the first
he's opened some eyes tonight
there's a base hit for zander bogarts
and that interrupts the stretch of nine
in a row retired by the yankee
right-hander great outing by michael
king you bet what a fine effort by
michael king who is removed with one out
and one on in the sixth yeah look at the
numbers first inning
three hits and of course the damaging
home run since then three hits no runs
right on cue marwin gonzalez sends the
ball into the left field corner
that's going to score bogarts from
second
renfro's going to try it throw to the
plate is not in time five nothing boston
yeah that one just kind of hung about
thigh high inside corner perfect pitch
for a right hand hitter to drop the
barrel on it just got the hand he got
the right hand in they are just as
confused as we are watching this
how this lineup so capable
and largely the same one that dominated
last year can go so quiet aaron judge
has just gone deep classic yankee
stadium homer hit it toward the porch
just the second homer all year yielded
by native baldy and with it the yankees
are finally on the board just the
strength of aaron judge
see it's a pretty level swing right
there but there are more fly balls in
yankee stadium that go over the wall
than any other stadium and a big
opportunity now for rugnet of gore with
runners at first and second and two gun
and still nobody up in the boston
bullpen
on the ground to the right side of the
infield gonzalez has a hard time with it
then throws it away
urscella scores
oh that's a ball that gonzales has to
simply put in his pocket
he had no chance of getting a door at
first base he never really got in front
of the ball tried to kind of snag it
back in and then you're right maddie to
try to throw it
off balance like he did just better off
eating that one and seeing if vivaldi
can get out of it with the bases loaded
two gun bases empty for alex berdugo
verdugo's robbed on a great play by la
mayhew
yankees down to their final out tonight
gary sanchez the battery struck out
three times
a loss here tonight for the yankees will
be their eighth in their last 11 games
the next one too
did he check it
he did not the homeland officer bill
miller does that himself so barnes does
get his strikeout to end the game the
red sox do get their win their first at
yankee stadium in over two years
5-2 the final score in the bronx tonight